what's the deal with airplane
peanuts from interviewing Legends like
Tom sagora and Mark Norman yeah that's a
great uh YouTube channel joke World
check it out to covering all the drama
happening in the comedy world this is
going to be on the joke World podcast BL
is Jake Gomez and even reporting live
from the comedy Mothership and skankfest
these are the best joke World interview
moments from 2023 watching your special
Mostly stories my freshman year of
college was one of the main things that
really got me interested in comedy and
standup in general so it's just a really
cool thing to get to talk to you all
these years later thanks man thanks do I
appreciate that I like I said
congratulations on um on what you've
built and uh I think you know keep going
because you're filling something that
that that needs to be filled with like
that space I think it's very smart that
you did this I saw a few months ago I
was watching two bears one cave with I
think it was theovon and Tom sagora and
they just started talking about you in a
really positive way does that feel
insane to see two of the most famous
comedians on the internet at at least
let alone just in the comedy World start
talking about you out of the blue both
of those guys were always super nice to
me thinking about it when I left La Theo
called me one day just out of the blue
just checking in on me last night at at
the Wilbur I heard people talking about
bir and I know that a lot of people they
spend a lot of time with us they spend a
lot of time watching videos and and
podcasts and going to shows and you're
never really sure how these people are
in real life and I'm not saying that
there aren't [__] I'm sure that
there are some comedians that that
you're watching you and they might be
for the 99% of the ones that I was lucky
enough to meet on the church and and
throughout all this have been very very
nice to me very kind I I have no
illusions of being one of the biggest
comedians in the world if I could be a
headlining comedian like in the same
world as them if I could be at the at
the top level clubs that would be an
honor so it's uh it's great that they
they talk about me in a positive way and
and they like what I did and they liked
me so it means a lot filming your
special ath the mothership that's a big
deal so what was the process like
getting permission or just pitching the
idea of filming a special there in the
first place oh that was actually the
easiest part honestly because like from
you know from the moment I met uh I met
Rogan I mean well at least from the
moment he saw me being funny you know he
was like oh I support you however I can
whatever you need don't need trip and
you know and I never asked him for
nothing but then I was like Hey I want
to film my special here he was like yeah
I know that you uh filmed a special for
Netflix so were there any differences
recording your special at the mothership
or recording your standup half hour on
Netflix as far as constraints or
freedoms with the entire process well
yeah yeah because the you know the half
hour is not that's produced those were
produced by Netflix God damn it Millie
okay all right you know there's there's
a lot less input in terms of you know
the look and the feel and you know you
don't have a lot of input in terms of of
of you know the way the set is set up
and the lighting and none of that stuff
there was one room during the special
where it started off what you'd probably
call a bad crowd or kind of a rough
crowd but it turned around in the end
how much of a risk is it shooting a
special in front of a random crowd
instead of advertising it to your
specific fans buddy it's one of the 1100
occupational hazards that came with this
project because uh yeah dude again and
the problem with that that you're
talking about the fat black bar and the
problem with that was that again I only
had one take at it so anytime anyone
films a special they almost always film
two t two shows so that way they have
coverage with this I did four rooms so I
had to do double the coverage but there
was only one shot at the bar and as I
leave in the credits you can see uh
where Ian Finance is hosting they are
Dum not all the shows are going to be
great and you know the first I don't
know 11 to 12 minutes of my set I'm just
just taking grenades in the trenches man
just nothing is nothing is hidden uh
it's to the point where I'm thinking in
my head I'm like I mean technically I
could just say I did all three rooms of
the comedy seller in one night and no
one's really G to know that I can just
cut this whole thing I was literally and
then um I got the light to like wrap up
and then I just uh just happened to talk
to the uh the the couple in the audience
who ended up having a fascinating
unbelievable insane weird story and um
and then you know I got to do the uh the
call back to the kids of and got an
Applause break which getting an Applause
break out of that crowd uh is felt
better than any other Applause break
I've ever gotten because they were so
anti seemingly anti-comedy the fact that
I got them to that level um like Ian was
in the back being like yeah he was just
like fist fing because it was it was
really a Hail Mary buzzer beater it was
a great walk-off home run I mean it was
all of that in with like literally the
last 30 seconds so that was uh that was
awesome to do and I am glad I pulled
that out yeah and with one take too that
just makes the whole story even better
yeah that's what was uh that was what
made it uh that was what made it scary
you know so what does that feel like
sitting around today I know you're on
the road you're busy but you're waiting
for this massive video to come out that
you've put years of work into now it's
just kind of all out of your hands so
what does that feel like leading up to
the premere later tonight oh well it
yeah it comes out tomorrow and I uh I
just I just want to get it over with
it's been such a goddamn nightmare with
the pr I hired a publicist he's charging
me a million dollars I've done so many
podcasts and interviews I'm on the
toilet right now because I'm out of time
I I'm at a hotel I'm at a shitbox hotel
in Lancaster my key didn't work so I
went to the front desk and he was like
oh you're supposed to be checked out
it's 4 pm so now he's he's waiting
outside my door and I was like I just
got to take a [__] so he's letting me
[__] and pack and then I got to go find
somewhere to shower but this is the road
folks I saw you mention on Chrissy chaos
that Netflix gives you like a certain
amount of money basically and then you
have to decide how much to spend on
producing the special then how much to
keep is that kind of right yeah yeah
it's kind of a [__] deal but they
they're smart businessmen because they
know we want to be on Netflix so they
give you a couple a couple bucks you got
to shoot it edit it promote it all the
stuff they used to
do uh and then you own it in two years
that's the big catch so that that's
pretty good we're here at skang fest
with Ian dance America's number one
comedian yeah Ian skankfest features
over 90 different comedians who is the
most underrated comedian at skankfest
who would that be oh my God what a
question um I don't know dude I love
Brendan sagalo so much he's the [__]
[__] his podcast is breaking up but like
a phoenix he's going to Rise From the
Ashes and I'm encouraging to focus on
comedic rap he's so good at freestyling
okay and who would the most
overrated speaking of the mother ship
though you were just on an episode of
kill Tony uh the episode came out last
week and you witnessed a golden ticket
winner right in front of your eyes kind
of a wild moment what was that like
seeing that unfold live when Heath
walked out on stage I think I'm
visibly seen asking like what the [__]
is going on multiple times um when he
came out man it was just like what the
hell what you know Jana said maybe the
funniest thing that nobody heard cuz he
just said it he didn't say it into the
microphone he just said it to me he
literally just looked at me and was like
what the hell is that thing and it just
was so goddamn funny because people kep
were so torn between like is he lying
about his age what's this dude's story
uh you know and then he was killing
obviously gets a standing ovation kills
um and then like Tony said it was like
every question that you asked him made
you think of 14 other questions you
wanted to ask him so I mean I have a
thousand more the fact that he doesn't
know the exact thing that's going on
with him is to me I I still haven't
slept thinking about it would be my only
mission in life I'd be I'd be up on the
Internet 23 hours a day and then the
other hour would be you know jerking off
or whatever but it's uh it was yeah it
was a wild one it was if it was one of
those moments where everybody all of us
sitting on it like the second it was
over we all looked at each other being
like we just we just witnessed a
legendary uh moment in this Show's
history you did so well on kill Tony
that people now are starting to say that
the bucket might be rigged somehow is
that a compliment for you and do you
have anything to say to those people who
think that the fix was in on your bucket
pole it very much is a compliment I'm
very flattered that people think that if
it is rigged I don't know about it I've
never met Tony before that Monday I had
a very huge moment me a couple months
ago where I was on a show with him but I
don't think he even knew I was there I
was like third on the lineup he was last
so yeah we never even met met but um it
was it was very cool that we met that
way and once you walked on stage you
immediately got to laugh just by saying
the words I feel like I feel
like did you know that if you ever got
pulled that it was going to be a really
big moment or did it click during your
set like wow I'm doing something very
special right now yeah I I knew it would
take people off but I mean I've seen a
lot of people crush and so I didn't know
exactly how it would turn out you know I
wasn't betting on anything but yeah it
turned out way better than I thought it
would be uh that voice crack completely
organic it helped everything definitely
got the ball rolling but uh yeah I
didn't expect it to turn out the way it
would now well like you mentioned before
you got to ask some real questions about
if washcloths are for the poor which has
been a classic YH debate that's been
going on for a long time now and has
plenty of people actually angry which
you've doubled down on but it's not even
close to the craziest thing you've ever
said on a podcast so as a comedian does
it ever surprise you what people choose
to get upset at versus what they can
accept as a joke it it surprises you
like the moment you go oh wow but then
you go like yeah this is what people do
you know um because they also you also
realize that in like if you want to use
watch Claus as an example the way that
that kind of went viral is that somebody
Clips like 30 seconds of a conversation
and then somebody who has no idea who
you are or what this is just sees that
and they go oh [__] this is like very
inflammatory the way that this is said
and they don't get that it's kind of
part of a longer larger conversation and
that it's that you're basically like
doing a bit right but you don't get any
of that when they clip it out but I'm
also used to that like the idea that
somebody will take you know a line from
a special and they'll they'll print it
and so somebody reads that and they go
this is crazy that you said this and
you're like yeah but that's part of a
larger thing going on so I'm not
surprised that people get upset but yeah
I think in the moment you go this is
what you're fired up about like yeah and
then you just kind of have to go with it
you know I'm sure I can guess what it
would be but do you have an official
prediction of what's to happen in the
rooming uh official prediction is I'm
going to knock him out in the second
round I'm pull down his pant I'm start
sucking this right in the r first Lew
Jak
[Applause]
g
g a different Festival like moon tower
for example there's a bunch of different
clubs at different spots do you prefer
that as a comedian or do you not even
really it's better here because the
worst part is like the travel and like I
said the shows are great but it gets in
the way of the hang and this is like the
only time we can all be together we're
all not on the road you know it's the
best and so having a spot where you can
go go go is like great man and um the
shows are like packed everyone's here
like those other festivals are great but
it's like it's like seven locals and
then like somebody from like [__] WME
that like knows nothing about comedy
they majored in business and now they're
trying to get in on the get down it's
like [__] that this is the best Festival
because it's all about the fans there's
no [__] industry [__] it's all
people that dig you and they're coming
up to you and like they get a chance to
be like dude I I work a [__] job I
hate you get me through it and that's
like the best [__] thing ever and
it's direct to the fans it's right to
them and that's why they it makes this
one the best [__] Festival he it's me
Ian fance whoa what's going on everyone
rock and roll
forever yo the [__] on forever yeah hey
Rock the vote unless you're voting to
decriminalize being gay in which case
that rules yeah that's awesome that it
seems like this is just so much of a
passion project for for you like you
didn't even have any plans for anyone
else to hear it besides you and Paul it
sounds like but you just want to do it
anyway which I feel like is really
authentic and and cool and one of the
things that I feel like makes you one of
the most interesting people in comedy
because you have this music side you
have the standup side and then you also
on top of that obviously own your
sandwich shop in New York city so I got
to ask you this question I feel like
it's pretty obvious but [__] Mary kill
between standup comedy making music and
Joey roses well thank you for all that
it was very nice what you just said I
mean I'd [__] Joey roses because it's
it's you know it's fun being in the bar
and sandwich business but it's a
different kind of work that I hadn't
been used to in a long time it's not the
Arts it's like no it's a business
there's a building there and needs to
make money so it's fun it's fun to dip
into I love the brand and I love what
we're doing but the business part of it
is not my favorite thing to live and
breathe every day yeah but I am
attracted to it I want to [__] it
I mean I'd marry uh the the the band
only because you know I listen to music
and every day you know constantly not
con but consistently I don't listen to
standup every day you know right so I
guess I'd have to kill standup but we
had a good run 23 years like if you know
whatever if I rick your onstage Persona
is very self-deprecating and unsure of
himself at times but you've been super
straightforward in calling out Hans Kim
on multiple occasions now where does
this confidence come from and is it
different than your confidence on stage
that's a very good question I don't know
where the confidence comes from my
Persona on stage is very
self-deprecating because I have an
agenda behind what I'm saying right so I
want to be self-deprecating and I want
to show that it's okay to make fun of
yourself and to not take your life too
seriously cuz we're just going to die
I'm a little bit of a nihilist you know
so I I really do believe that a lot of
things don't really matter that a lot of
things that we attach importance to are
just going to perish whether be either
before or after us and I think that that
can seem a little bit depressing but
it's actually giving me a lot of
confidence but once you accept certain
things in life the outcome doesn't
matter like if I'm on kill Tony that's a
bonus I want the lottery if if I figure
out that I can challenge hands Kim I
mean I know he takes it personally
because he sees it as his job I see it
as it is a competitive world where we
all have to fight for anything and he's
been challenged numerous times and he's
won every single Challenge and he's got
more experience than me so for me it was
more about the experience of it you're a
Kil Tony fan right of course yep so you
have seen every single or almost every
single previous golden ticket winner
right how many of them do you see
regularly on the show just you yeah
that's a good point so what's the value
of that golden ticket that especially as
a foreigner there are at least two or
three other golden ticket winners who
live in Austin right now Chandler
welcome to the show thank you for being
with us here today please tell us what's
it look like out there the scene leading
up to the first ever kill Tony at Joe
Rogan's club uh everyone seems really
excited Jake uh everyone seems to be
lining up there's a huge line out here
outside lots of comics from all over the
place from Canada and New York just from
all over just trying to sign up for this
show uh the energy seems very great uh
people are seem very excited and uh I
think people really want to see uh what
it's like to be on the main stage of
this new great uh comedy venue now as
far as you can tell are there any people
out there trying to scalp or sell
tickets uh as far as I can tell Jake no
one here is uh trying to scalp tickets
or anything like that um if anything I
feel like the uh the crew here at the
Mother Ship are kind of keeping a watch
out for that so people don't get scammed
uh out of uh this uh great show uh that
they're about to put on here for kill
Tony and Chandler you're a local
comedian yourself in Austin what's the
scene like what's the vibe in the comedy
community with this big news The Joe
Rogan Comedy Club opening and receiving
a lot of national attention I believe
everyone's really excited I think it
gives people a really great opportunity
um to to get on to this show uh I think
people um are are really just trying to
show what they've got uh and people seem
very very excited would you stab
somebody for a spot tonight I would stab
everyone in this line for for 2 minutes
wow wow you heard it here first dude
Jake people are out here willing to kill
to get into this Comedy Club hi Jake I'm
here on the scene with mass Wayne Mass
what do you how do you feel about Tony
and it being at the mothership for the
first time in it
opening uh I feel the same I guess
Charles Adams Jr uh Charles how do you
feel about this uh you know this first
kill Tony on a Monday at the comedy
Mothership uh man it's all good my feet
hurt I wish they give us some chairs or
something would you stab a guy for a
chair I will [__] a dude up right here
on Sixth Street right here for a
[__] chair I would hard too
yeah everyone's saying they would stab
for a chair right now or just stab
people to get in uh I wouldn't stab
anybody man just just straight hands you
know what I mean wow that's a real man
right there yeah just [__] crush them
you know what I mean I totally
understand you Charles you don't feel
like anything in your life has changed
do you feel like you're going to get any
opportunities out of this uh I feel
exactly the same I feel how I always
feel that's just how I feel all the time
I can be getting my dick sucked right
now and I feel the same yeah I was
actually talking to some people on this
line and they said that uh most people
in this line uh had the same dick size
as this
microphone yeah Austin is full of honky
so that's probably true I haven't seen
many Asians though right on well Jake
I've interviewed quite a few people uh
people seem very excited uh it sounds
like people would stab people uh which
you know what that's fair you know I
mean the show is called kill Tony uh as
you can see there's a lot of people in
this line people are very excited and
are anticipating the arrival of this
show and this club uh you know we're
going to see how it goes and uh I also
signed up myself so uh we'll see how it
goes your last special on YouTube is
currently at around 12 million views you
were very early on the YouTube wave for
comedians putting on full specials to
their own channels was there any
hesitancy to go with Netflix this time
after seeing just how perfectly it
worked on YouTube last time or was it
always a goal to have a fulllength 50
minute special hour special on Netflix
regardless another great question boy
you know your you know your comedy Biz I
try um yeah it's great it's great having
a guy on the other side because all the
comedians know all this [__] then you
can't talk to anybody about it who's not
a comedian but you're you're a nerd like
us basically I love YouTube YouTube is
great it's great for comedy these
Gatekeepers suck you know they're it's a
business at the end of the day so they
they got no balls they don't want to
take a risk on a guy or a gal or a
non-binary but I think I got the YouTube
crowd I feel like I won that fight and
then I'm like let me see if I can win
the Netflix crowd and I'll own it in two
years anyway so I can just put it on
YouTube so it's a win-win and you get a
couple bucks so I figure hey let's mix
it up and I get it back anyway that
makes a lot of sense that seems awesome
I just have one more question for you in
this new age of comedians making things
independently uh a lot of people are
self-producing things many comedy fans
just assume that any show produced by a
network could be overly PC or a little
watered down so on this show will you be
able to say stuff like Bing Fung into
the Duck Sauce yes I will be I I'm
saying things even worse than being Fung
into the D sa on this show actually you
know I Gotta Give vice TV credit and
kimot credit they really let a lot of
the edgier stuff stay in the show and
they fought for it as much as they can
so I respect that yeah so so you will
this is uh you know it's on late at
night so this this is why it's it's it's
one of those things where it's like they
kind of just let us go for it which I I
I respect from what you can remember uh
from filming the church do you have a
favorite moment or memory from producing
the Church of What's Happening Now
Ralphie May with like with focus on the
yellow has to to be one of the best
meeting Gabriel glacius was was
fantastic Mike Tyson was fantastic uh
Henry Rollins was super very kind to me
one of my favorite moments one of the
times that we had Dice Clay on was
fantastic because after the podcast he
he just he was sitting next to me and
dice looked over and said hey have you
ever thought about doing standup and I
hadn't I had never done standup didn't
think I was that kind of funny and that
was my like impetus I guess for starting
standup wow that's when I I went to open
mics and and Joey told me about the
fourth wall and it went from there so
for better or worse I guess you can
blame Dice Clay for me starting stand
but who knows maybe he asks everyone
that has it ever been hard at shows that
aren't as perfect for comedy like kill
Tony to get across exactly how funny you
are to just a random unruly crowd
sometimes I've had some bad shows but
usually what it is is people are just
like what the hell is about to happen
and then sometimes they hear the words
that come out of my mouth M and they
don't like it so much so if anything
like I can usually get their attention
because they're like look at this little
boy about to go on stage but sometimes
they don't like it very much and that's
the problem we saw on Instagram on the
comedy Mothership Instagram you hanging
out with a bunch of comedians at mits
after the show how was that experience
and was there any really cool moments
that you want to share or maybe the
coolest person that you got to meet yeah
I mean that was just absolutely insane I
got to you have a really special moment
with Tony I had a really special moment
with Shane backstage right before I got
on he was like giving me a pep talk and
that was crazy it was like he was my
guardian angel it was weird but yeah it
was super cool I don't have much words
for it cuz it was just I I never
expected anything like that to happen at
all you're kind of an old school guy
what do you think about what's going on
in Austin right now kind of becoming a
third City I mean I love I love all
these other scenes coming up it's always
to me I'm so I'm so old school that it
just shocks me that these small smaller
towns and Austin is a good siiz city but
can can I I I don't I I'm still can't
wrap my mind around how much comedy
people want to consume in this in the
world right now it's it was so not
popular when I started that I still
don't really understand like wow the
amount of tickets that are selling
everywhere is crazy you know I don't
know how long Austin can really support
all these clubs and all the things I
mean at the same time are there enough
people there is it enough of a tourist
destination to do that I've been to the
Mothership it's a very beautiful Club I
know I think that's uh it's really cool
but also there I feel like I love it but
there there needs to be more bigger
Comics coming there they they don't they
need a deeper bench is what I would say
you know they got to bring up the some
of the locals or some bigger people need
to move there because you look at it and
there's like there's great Comics but it
seems to be like the same few Comics
every week when unless there's a big
guest coming through a lot of times
there are but I just think to run a
showcase show where there's local I mean
man people love Joe Rogan and they'll
see Joe Rogan every night of the week
and I and I guess I guess he can sustain
it but it would be cool if it became you
know truly like these other cities
anying out of the week you're seeing
like six Headliners you know which would
be great and right now it's mostly you
know it's it's Brian Simpson it's Tony
Hinchcliffe it's it's Joe Rogan and it's
Ron White and hopefully Tom or Christina
are in town too you know what I mean
those like the fact that I can name the
comics who are going to be there at any
given night you know so I I think it's a
beautiful Club I think he's done a lot
to really make it a Comics comedy club
and I just wish the the the bench was
deeper and and more comics will move out
there those Comics I mention
amazing comics and you could see them
night did I mention and Ron White's
there you know those are those are great
Comics to see all the time but it would
be cool if there was even a larger
community of comics to support that club
is what I would say is it true that Hans
invited you over to play Katan with him
and his girlfriend and do you feel any
sense of betrayal calling him out so
many times after starting like a
friendship I had met Hans Kim once for a
podcast once in a show and one set a
show and once when he invited me over to
play Katan and I appreciated the gesture
and I do still want to be friends with
him on the other hand does that the fact
that I go to play Katan to his house
mean I should forgo any professional
Ambitions I have if I had asked him for
permission before challenging him and he
had said no then wouldn't I be a worse
person for still doing it yeah I'm not
saying what I did isn't selfish but I
also feel like it's not that to that
unfair especially challenging someone
who again is filling out theaters has
been on the show for over two years is
doing great has a great fan base he's a
great comedian I find him to be funny
edgy and he's pushing boundaries in what
he's doing and I don't want to take him
out of the Kil Tony family that's not
the purpose I don't want to not be
friends with him I don't want to
discredit him but I feel like I've been
given a chance where I was put in a
position where I could do this and I'd
be an idiot not to do it well we've all
seen Bobby as a hilarious comedic actor
but in death and ramen there's some more
serious scenes and tones how would you
rate him as a dramatic actor I think
he's the best I think that a lot of
comedians um tend to have like a real
feel for tragedy and drama but aren't
necessarily given the space to do so I
think that Bobby historically has you
know he's been on Mad TV and he's played
a lot of stereotypical characters kind
of to be a supporting character and to
be the butt of the joke I was inspired
to cast him in a more dramatic role that
still utilized his you know very funny
and comedic chops but I was inspired
when I saw the 300th episode of tiger BT
where over the course of that episode
you know he was so vulnerable and open
uh with his friend David Cho and Steven
Yun and it just sort of introduced me to
a version of Bobby that I hadn't seen
before it was a version that was very
sensitive and kind of dark you you
always knew that there was Darkness
that's there but the vulnerability felt
fresh to me and that's when I knew that
uh he had what it took to to do it and
just was never offered the the platform
who is one dream interview that you've
had for this Show comedian or not if you
could have anyone in the hot seat to ask
them dating questions who would it be I
have been begging the studio to let my
gynecologist come on okay not exp I I
feel like talking to the guy that looks
at my vagina for fun that is the kind of
person that I really want to talk to and
find out like what is it like because
it's like it's supposed to be what is it
like to date the person across from me
and I'm so curious what it would be like
to date someone
that's a man that just looks at vagina
on vagina vag like how do you yeah you
know I be so insecure I'd be like how
does my vagina look compared to all the
other ones like you know so I don't know
I think that in my [__] up little
world that's where that's who I would
like to talk to that is such an
unexpected answer I was expecting like
uh Joe Rogan or some crazy
L gentl here's the Twitter pole would
you rather see Berke crer finally put on
a [__] shirt or a Sam Talent put on a
pair of pants with these grotesque
[__] legs like you should be wearing
those sleeves I'm wearing one stupid oh
you are oh you're
gross you're the and you're still you
have [__] open puls that you have to
hide he can't just let go
I would let go of my vintage suits if he
would just put on some
trousers and make them in my size bro
well maybe you should change
sizes people are just excited to go into
this building to see Jokes which I feel
like is very rare oh yeah yeah it's
awesome I mean if if you're a comedy fan
you got you have to come to the
Mothership at least once yeah you know I
think that's what a lot of people are
doing but also if you a if you're a
comedian you got to come to the
Mothership at least once it's the only
only Club where all the money goes into
the club every other Comedy Club has to
survive and the mothership don't have to
do that we all see those pictures of the
uh the red neon don't be a [__] sign
and that cool snake table and all that
stuff how how dope is actually being in
that green room and hanging out with
people oh man it's amazing honestly man
I laugh more in that green room than I
do anywhere else I guess that is that is
a a little a little uh a little taste
that most people don't get to to
experience but no it's it's amazing it's
it's one of the nice nicest green rooms
I've been in for sure all right well
last question for you here Brian I I
really appreciate your time today um is
it true that you have a special pair of
Crocs that you only wear on stage and
were those featured at all in the
special well you know what's funny that
used to be true no let me let me let me
rephrase that that's that is true now I
used to wear my Crocs to the club and
then change into shoes before I went on
stage M and change back in the Crocs and
then I think it was um I think it was
Andrew Schultz that was like why don't
you just wear the Croc on stage that's I
mean that's what you want to do yeah you
know cuz he asked me why like why do you
do that I'm like oh cuz my the Sho the
shoes hurt my feet I got you know and
he's like why don't you just wear the
Crocs then and I'm like you know that's
not a bad idea who gives a [__] ahead of
this big kill Tony show coming up what
is the largest crowd you've performed in
front of up to now Tony take me on the
RO do theater stuff so the theater that
we've been doing probably the biggest is
like like 4,000 3,000 something like
that nice the biggest number right now
is life changing to like know you want
to do something real bad and to be able
to do it every week it's like it's it's
it's it's a surreal feeling well Heath
we're talking to you a few weeks before
the kill Tony arena show up to this
point what is the largest crowd you've
ever performed in front of so far yeah
so just recently about a month ago I got
to go on Tony or tour with Tony for a
little bit and I did about 3,000 seats
in Phoenix and so that was really
helpful I'm glad I got that because
before I got to do those those shows
with Tony it was only about 400 so I
can't even imagine going from 400 to
8,000 we've heard a lot about what it
feels like to perform at the mothership
interviewing various comedians but you
also work there what is that experience
like it's like the coolest job ever you
feel what I'm saying I I had some jobs
but it just like feel like college you
know saying I ain't never went to
college so kind of meeting all the big
comedian like that WM on the clock and
like I mean cuz being a door guy like
that's a big thing bro like working
there is like one of is one of the best
I've had like as a person I'm saying do
you feel more connected to the kill Tony
family or or the mothership family or
does that all blend into one it all one
family yeah it's all one big family you
know I'm saying it just got different
like you know saying like cous and [__]
one it's one big ass yeah for sure no
different everybody in there like call
like my mom you feel what I'm saying
like that place the reason I didn't get
home sick real quick like I've been
there like nine months I I ain't get
home sick CU it feel like home you feel
me well your old home is here in Florida
I'm based out of Tampa right now but you
got a lot of people coming in from
Florida to Austin what is that like
everyone kind of following your
footsteps and and expecting you to take
him to the promised land in this new
comedy Mecca I mean it's cool I just
like to show people like that I think
it's really funny like you if you want
to come out here it's it's show it's
stage time Ain no ain't no greenness in
my heart you know saying this place
Chang my life so I would like other
people that I that I'm really cool with
or I think it's very funny you know I'm
saying too you feel me cuz it's so it's
so much I a going to hurt me T home but
I'm cooling on the show you know what
I'm saying so much [__] going on so
you've been able to spend some more time
in Austin since we last spoke make some
more appearances on the show how's this
crazy kill Tony ride been for you since
the last appearance that you've made on
joke world yeah it's been so much fun
I've meeting so many cool people and
I've done a lot of cool things like I
said I got to go and do my first
theaters with Tony and that's an
experience I'll never forget hey what's
going on joke world I'm Sunny Carlin
over here at ACL live for the 10 year
anniversary of kill Tony so to the day
it's been 10 years my name is DK we're
here at kill Tony 10 my name is Audrey
Scott comedian we got these Earth fans
not sure where they're going to put us
but uh hopefully it has a bathroom and a
nice cool refreshing drink I'm onita and
I just [__] showed up I didn't know
anything I have my sister like in the
car running and so it's the 10th
anniversary killed Tony and hopefully
like get [__] pick for one have you
signed up before yeah for like like
almost 2 years and everybody that I meet
gets picked except for [__] Me Make
some noise for
Wanita we're all going to meet her
together Wanita oh [__] here we go let's
[__] go why'd you sign up uh I think
uh Tony this show right here just
podcast does a lot for the comics
especially the working Comics uh
unfortunately a lot of people sign up
that not ready for comedy uh but also
that's kind of what makes the show uh
but the good Comics they actually uh you
know they get a little recognition and
they show their hard work it's a great
opportunity I think kill Tony has made
more people famous than American Idol
which I think is a huge accomplishment
you
know please let me know what Willam
Montgomery sing I'm in red if you get
pulled tonight are you ready oh shoot
I'm always [__] ready dude my life
man like I'm I'm ready I'm ready I would
love to be pulled I'm really here is uh
I hope Jared Nathan kills it shout out
to Jared love you so much kill it dude
if you get pulled tonight are you ready
yeah I'm ready yeah I'm not nervous at
all oh yeah of course I'm ready I'm
always ready anytime they're uh ready to
pull me which is kind of what I'm
waiting for every time I'm back here I'm
going to go with what I got if it
doesn't work it's only going to be a
minute of hell you can't even die in a
minute yeah you can kill in a that you
can't die put your hands together for
Kent Hunter everyone Kent
[Applause]
Hunter how' it go it was good really
love here we go Kent Hunter everybody
makes a noise for him his first time on
Kil Tony he didn't know it was my second
time he was like you ever been on he
said oh this the first time and he like
what's the biggest crowd you ever done I
was like when I was on here last time
open he was like
oh that dude were like shaking more than
Jerry little nervous is that why your
entire lower half is shaking right now
probably that is incredible do we have a
camera zoomed in on that for the love of
God holy [__] that is unbelievable I
didn't talk much in the interview they
were just joking on me the
whole the leging leg what do you think
about joke world and kill Aly
collaborating
I'm pretty stoked it means more people
are going to say I've Down syndrome than
before so I'm excited about
that watching all your [__] comments
too now that I know I'm never going to
stop looking and to finally wrap up this
crazy year voting is now open for the
joke World Awards a fand driffin Comedy
Award Show voted on solely by the
subscribers of this channel categories
for the joke World Awards include
comedian of the Year podcast of the Year
podcast guest of the Year special of the
year not on YouTube YouTube special of
the year and newcomer of the Year voting
is officially open right now so you can
use the link in our bio to start voting
every single day until the winners are
announced have fun voting for your
favorite comedians to win tell your
friends if they like comedy that this is
happening and thank you so much for
watching P joke
world that's J
world and the world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
world check it out